welcome back to CBS this morning we're
gonna begin in Washington where in just
hours house managers will resume their
opening argument in president Trump's
Senate impeachment trial for more than
eight hours yesterday Democrats use
testimony text emails and even the
president's own words they argued he led
an effort to withhold a White House
meeting and nearly 400 million dollars
in security aid for Ukraine unless its
president publicly announced an
investigation into former Vice President
Joe Biden and his son Republicans say
that ukrainian president vladimir
zalenski himself said that he felt no
pressure from mr. Trump Democrats tried
to punch holes in that defense claiming
zalenski would say anything because
Ukraine badly needed that military aid
which it did eventually receive like
they're gonna admit they were being
shaken down by the Prez of the United
States they're at war and they're being
told you're not getting four hundred
million in aid you need unless you do
what the president wants and what the
president wants are these two
investigations if you don't believe
that's pressure that's four hundred
million dollars worth of pressure I got
a bridge I want to sell you on his way
home from Switzerland President Trump
tweeted or retweeted 142 times yesterday
I believe that's a record for this
president slamming his impeachment as a
hoax well there are seven house
impeachment managers presenting the
Democrats case one of them as New York
congressman Hakeem Jeffries he joins us
from Capitol Hill in an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning there he is
good morning to you congressman morning
great to be with you we're great we're
very glad you're here you and your
colleagues are laying out what some are
calling a detailed extraordinary and
some say excruciating case to remove the
president do you think you're getting
through to any of the Republicans who
are listening well that is certainly my
hope our case has been straightforward
the facts are unconverted and the
evidence is overwhelming as it relates
to what has taken place here the
president pressured a foreign government
to target an American citizen for
political
game at the same time withheld 391
million dollars in military aid from a
vulnerable ally that remains at war with
Russian backed separatists in the east
we've heard this I'm curious about how
do you cut through when the defense is
saying the president in particular it's
a hoax there's nothing to see here it's
a big sham how do you cut through what
appears to be just one big talking point
I think people say congressman we've
heard all of this before most important
to understand what the fundamental
allegations are here as it relates to
the abuse of power that has taken place
and then within that context we have
presented witness testimony after
witness testimony including individuals
who were trump appointees like Gordon
Sandlin who indicated that everyone was
in the loop and it was a quid pro quo we
have testimony from ambassador Bill
Taylor a West Point graduate Vietnam War
hero another administration appointee he
indicated that there was no legitimate
reason for the withholding of the aid
we're going to make our case with facts
and witnesses and evidence and documents
well congressman when you make that case
and you look out on the floor of
senators we've seen reports that some
were doing crossword puzzles some doze
off do you feel that you have their
attention and that they are receptive to
the evidence that you're bringing forth
well they'll ultimately have to decide
the question of receptivity but but you
can tell when you're when you're
addressing a crowd I mean you can tell
if people are paying attention to you or
not do you get the sense that people are
paying attention my sense has been that
the senators on both sides of the aisle
are actually paying attention they are
absorbing the information some of them
have acknowledged that the information
that they are receiving they are hearing
and processing for the first time that's
a good thing a significant number of
Americans are hearing this information
for the first time and that's an
important thing because what this is all
about at the end of the day is what kind
of democracy we are going to have in
America no one's above the law
congressman the big lingering question
seems to be whether there will be
additional witnesses in this Senate
trial that there was some discussion
essentially a witness swap with john
bolton and one of the Biden's Senator
Schumer said today that's
said that's off the table is there
possible possible deal out there that
would put witnesses before the Senate do
you think well that's a decision that
will ultimately have to be made by all
100 senators and there are different
perspectives that we are hearing from a
variety of them I'll leave that to the
deliberations that will take place but
here's what I do know that in America a
fair trial involves witnesses and
involves evidence it involves documents
it involves a presentation of the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth and ultimately the Senators will
come down on whatever side of this
constitutional question that they think
is appropriate but they should hear all
of the information before making that
decision they should hear from John
Bolton they should hear from Mick
Mulvaney they should hear from the other
witnesses that the president has hidden
from the American people is there any
chance the house could still subpoena
John Bolton well that's a question that
remains to be seen speaker Pelosi has
indicated that she hasn't ruled it in
and she hasn't ruled it out we're still
making the case to those senators in to
the American people today we will be
applying the law to the facts that have
been set forth which made clear that the
President did attempt to solicit a thing
of value which is phony investigations
into Joe Biden and his son as well as
this Russian conspiracy theory in
exchange for taxpayer dollars and in
exchange for an oval office meeting all
right well if you don't know now you
know were you trying to provide a moment
of levity or were you just trying to
make a point
quoting big well well you know it was a
spontaneous utterance as they say
related to what came out George
Washington perhaps made the most
important point and I quoted him
yesterday which is that the Constitution
is sacredly obligatory upon all that
means everyone including the President
of the United States all right
congressman Jeffries we're gonna have to
leave it there I'm sure we'll talk to
you again thank you sir for taking the
time thank you very much